si vous voulez bien vous gagnez vos
places la séance est ouverte
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement la parole est à monsieur
jean marie sermier
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame marisol touraine ministre les
affaires sociales de la santé et du
droit des femmes madame la ministre
on le savait depuis longtemps
le président de la république n'aime pas
les riches en vérité il n'aime pas les
autres non plus la modulation des
allocations familiales en fonction des
revenus qui entre en vigueur aujourd'hui
1er juillet le confirme le confirme
malheureusement en effet cette mesure
n'affectera pas les plus aisés mais bien
les classes moyennes c'est à dire celles
qui font le dynamisme de notre pays
concrètement un couple avec deux enfants
dont un parent travail y perdra dès lors
qu'ils gagnent plus de 2300 30 euros par
mois
on ne peut pas sérieusement parler de
riches pour un salaire de 2000 330 euros
par mois gauthier ya quatre personnes au
foyer par la modulation des allocations
familiales
vous continuez à matraquer les familles
les allocations familiales n'ont pas été
créées pour rééquilibrer les revenus
mais pour compenser la charge de la
famille pour la première fois depuis
1945 un gouvernement remet en cause
l'égalité devant la naissance de
l'enfant
voilà le triste prolongement de tous les
coups que vous leur avez donné
diminution du quotient familial
réduction de la prime de naissance
fiscalisation des majorations de
pensions de famille nombreuse
madame la ministre quand allez vous
reconnaître que la famille et la
vitalité démographique de notre pays et
qu'elles sont notre meilleur atout
sortir durablement de la crise
économique merci la parole est à mme
haddad marisol touraine ministère des
affaires sociales de la santé et des
droits des femmes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
sermier oui les familles sont
extrêmement importante pour notre pays
c'est pour cela que nous maintenons
l'universalité des allocations
familiales des côtes aura continué à
percevoir des allocations familiales
mais la justice monsieur le député la
justice c'est que les familles qui ont
moins reçoivent plus et à partir
d'aujourd'hui nous mettons en place une
réforme de justice de modulation des
allocations familiales qui va concerner
monsieur le député 10 % des familles ce
ne sont pas les classes moyennes lorsque
10 % des familles sont concernées sauf
le séjour tout le revenu est supérieure
à 6000 euros net par mois vont voir
leurs allocations familiales diminué
diminué par deux lorsqu'elles sont deux
enfants
c'est notre conception de la justice
parce que nous voulons pouvoir donner
plus à d'autres familles et je voudrais
monsieur meunier garde bosca mesdames et
messieurs de l'opposition parlé de ces
familles modestes qui ont plusieurs
enfants dont les revenus sont inférieurs
à 2000 euros par mois et qui vont voir
leurs allocations familiales augmenté de
1000 euros par an au cours du
quinquennat déjà 350 euros alors à
laquelle je vous parle je voudrais que
vous parliez de la revalorisation des
allocations familiales pour les familles
monoparentales
parce que ça c'est de la justice c'est
de la justice sociale c'est la justice
familiale entre l' équilibre de la vie
professionnelle et de la vie familiale
nous n'avons sans doute pas la même
conception de la justice sociale
monsieur le député mais nous avons la
volonté d'aider les familles toutes les
familles dans notre pays parce que
toutes les familles doivent être aidés
et toutes les familles doivent être
reconnus merci madame lamy